[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cache before we
even start and I asked if people on the
app can see me or I can hear me
because I wanted to make sure it was
working and somebody wrote down on my
app loud and clear so we're good loud
and clear
we are good hmm
so look you guys it's it's on babies you
know I'm saying I'm having a I'm having
a good time in life and you know doesn't
my back hurt yes is it all good that
about my tongue yes so does my [ __ ]
face hurt and my back hurt yes but I am
I truckin through life yes because
that's what you do I mean you know if
somebody were to come up to ask me on
the street hey dude
even though this has happened in my life
and these are the negative things do I
still have to truck through life I'd be
like yes that's what I would do so
that's what's up man and we're already
[ __ ] a minute and a half into this
podcast can you believe it can you
honestly believe it minute and a half in
and it's flying by congratulations
that's the episode that's the episode
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was I did I did a few things
recently I did a ch3 podcast didn't talk
about that you know I like those guys I
really like those guys on h3 and I
actually checked some of the comments
didn't mean to and but I was looking at
some comments and I really made me feel
good man a lot of people online a lot of
hate and [ __ ] but a lot of people on
those comments were saying like how
she liked the episode how much they
liked me as a guest and that really
makes me feel good
also my butthole hurts great that's cool
that's cool and it's weird that that
happened after I did the h3 podcast cuz
we always talk about using Metamucil and
I didn't use them at a Musil and because
I was staying in Albuquerque and flying
a lot dude how much just flying dry you
out Sahara
a Sahara dude when you fly you get so
dry and I didn't I don't even mean to
rap there but I rapped but when you fly
you get so dry and you know I'm not
gonna drink coffee and coffee does what
it dehydrates you so what happens is
when you go do number two instead of
doing number two it feels like a Brinks
truck is coming out of you it's all good
but it feels like a Brinks truck it
feels like you're like hey am I going to
the bathroom
or that's what I want to do when I'm dry
when I fly and go to Albuquerque well in
the desert and I'm drinking iced
Americanos till all the day is long and
when I go to the bathroom
I need this cuz it feels like a [ __ ]
freight trains coming out ah didn't mean
to gross you out three minutes in the
episode but what's real is real dude and
we don't [ __ ] around here at the
congratulations podcast we certainly
don't [ __ ] around it's all real [ __ ] and
I talk about what comes to my mind
because you can't you can't not you know
what I'm talking about I gotta be real I
was listening to my brother's podcast
mentally is confused and is it Joe Walsh
is that is that who was yeah Joe Walsh
was saying he can't even though he's
conservative but doesn't like Trump he
can't be on panels because they stick
they tell him to not bash Trump when
he's doing like Fox News stuff or
whatever it is I don't even know if it's
[ __ ] news but like when it's very
conservative panels and he's and they're
and and and other guys like Hannity will
just be the yes-man and be like oh yeah
of course I won't because this is the
job that Joe Walsh just he's like I
don't know what to do because I can't
lie about how I feel
and Jill wash that's what gets you a
gold medal did you understand that
that's what gets you a gold medal
because that's awesome dude because it's
weird when when when when journalists
are just on a [ __ ] agenda or uh what
do you call it
pundits or [ __ ] I don't know these
guys with this shows anytime I has a
show and it begins with you know don't
call the president you don't you know
what I mean don't be on the phone with
the president if you have a show that
goes like this it's just in we're here
and this is what happened is an
embattled outside of the jadon and
that's my take hello hello mr. president
can't talk to the president if you show
goes and you know it but it's all good
that's the world we live in now my
babies um so we are [ __ ] five minutes
into this podcast and we were just
flying we were just flying dude I swear
it seems like three minutes and it's
been five but love those guys over on h3
had a good time told some stories I
actually told this story and I realized
I never told this on the on the on the
on the podcast on this podcast but it's
funny because I this was insane
one time when I was I had to go to the
bathroom so bad number two and I hope
see Daisy I was in public but I don't
care dude you know what I do do you know
what I do when I gotta go to the
bathroom in public number two do you
know what I do I go bathroom in public
number two because that's how it is dude
that's how it is if toilets are around
I'm using them if I gotta go I don't
people with old germs and [ __ ] like that
that's how you get sick and I don't use
I don't you dude I only use the [ __ ]
the thing you know what I mean the the
cover I only use that when it's
necessary like if there's some blood on
the toilet seat or something I wipe it
off I get a lot of toilet paper
I wipe it off I wipe it off so it
doesn't touch my hand as well and then I
put the thing on only if there was like
blood or [ __ ] or piss but if there's
nothing on there and I look at it and
you know what I do I give it a once-over
that's all I do I give it a once-over
and if it's got nothing on there I don't
use it because it's just touching my
thighs do it if pitch touches your
thighs I don't give a [ __ ] bro I'm
living oh my god Chris you sat on though
you sat on the on the toilet bowl what
about getting piss and [ __ ] all over
your balls is it on my balls or is it on
my thighs so I do it and I don't give a
[ __ ] good because that's the kind of
life you got to live on gangster and if
you're out there and if you're going to
the bathroom number two and you're not
using those [ __ ] safety things let me
know and I won't read it but tweeted at
me and I won't read it so I don't do it
one time Oh also if if the woman's room
is open haha check that the man's room
if the men's room is is is [ __ ] used
occupied and the woman's is not I'm a
chick apparently I've got a [ __ ] cuz
I'm unloading unloading in the woman's
room dude
hey sir what are you doing it looks like
you got a penis and you're going in the
women's room
well apparently right now I'm a female
[Applause]
oh my god are you strangling an
alligator am i or am i taking a [ __ ] bro
so I went into the thing the ladies room
and it wasn't a single stall and guess
what dude you [ __ ] up the way you made
this building cuz this is still coming
out all right so I go in the woman's
room and I tiptoe because now I'm a
woman baby and I go in the stall you
know how women always tiptoe so I go in
the stall and I close the door and then
and then and then I close the door and
then and then I'm going right I'm going
and it's all good but I'm going there
wasn't an apple but even still we have
home with the keyboard so so I'm in
there and I'm going and a lady comes in
and instantly I don't know why maybe
it's because I'm a [ __ ] my knees get
real close to it to each other because
I'm scared and I don't want anybody to
see my balls and I'm trying to [ __ ]
be real real tiny so nobody could see me
even though I'm still 6 2 and I'm a tall
drink of water right and my shoulders of
course are [ __ ] they go on for like
do you want to know what the weather is
like on Thursday cuz my shoulders go
into next week you know I mean you want
to know what the [ __ ] weather is like
on next Thursday well let's take a ride
on my shoulders shoulders go on for a
week so let me know where you are and
I'll tell you the forecast all right so
are those your shoulders yes and it's
raining on Friday
anyway dude I went in there and my knees
were touching together cuz I scared cuz
the lady [ __ ] came in and she was
tiptoeing because she's a lady ladies
always tiptoe ladies have never not
tiptoed and I'm trying to be quiet I'm
trying not to let front come out or
anything like that you know I mean try
not to strangle any alligators and she's
like she says did a guy come in here did
anyone see it no she said did anyone see
a guy come in here and there's the
sliver of the V the way they make these
stalls dude make them so there's no way
to peek in you know there's always like
a gap that's like [ __ ] two inches
wide and you could just literally make
eye contact with people while you're
[ __ ] dropping off in and I mean so so
she looks at me after she said no she
said does anyone see a guy come in here
and I go like this I go like this I'm
like should I make my voice like a woman
like should I literally go no but I'm
like no I'm not gonna pass for that
right if it were nowadays I would have
just been like no and I know you've got
you hear my voice but I identify as a
woman I would have [ __ ] done that now
but this was a while ago so I just I was
like should I go no and I was like nah
for [ __ ] sake you know the one time
when I was a kid when someone I was a
kid I don't want to talk to him it was I
was in high scores in eighth grade and
this kid was actually wanted to hang out
I didn't want to hang out he had my
number cuz I had cell phones back then
and they called me and he was like hi I
picked up the phone and I was like hello
and he was like Chris and I was like
[ __ ] he's gonna ask to hang out and I
said oh no this is Chris's mom Ellie and
he was like oh is Chris there and I said
and I literally I literally said I this
is the truth I swear to god I literally
said oh no he's at the Opera he said
okay well tell him to call me back it's
David or whoever well I remember was and
I said okay click and I remember
thinking well he'll believe that because
why the [ __ ] would I pretend I was my
mom and say Chris was at the Opera
because what the [ __ ] there's no operas
that go on it [ __ ] well maybe they do
I don't know but not nothing near la
cañada at 5:00 p.m. so anyway I I didn't
do that voice I just I said she said did
anyone see a guy come in here and I said
no and I as I say no I look at out the
the crack of the doors and I'm making
eye contact with her with one eye and
I'm looking at her and I say no and she
just said did anyone see a guy come in
here and I say no and I'm a guy oh and
then oh no I didn't say no I said what I
said what which is even better that's
how much of a [ __ ] I was she said never
see a guy coming here and I said what
and I'm looking at her and she says and
I sand and then she says again and I
swear to god this was the only time
that's ever happened in my entire life
she said I said did anyone see an iPhone
in here
I heard the wrong thing because I was
scared I'm a [ __ ] that was the first
that was the only time that ever
happened to me it's like if that happens
in movies and you're like oh get go [ __ ]
yourself dude go [ __ ] yourself you know
but it really happened and I said oh no
no iPhone and she just walked out
tiptoeing like a lady and I finished up
strangling my alligator and then I
walked out a man but that was what was
up that day dude did you know that so it
was good man one time my friend said he
was in a foreign country with his
brother and he was drinking with his
brother and he and his brother come
finds brother for a little bit and he
was outside and there was a huge pile of
throw-up on the ground and he was
leaning up against the wall and
buddy said hey did you just throw up and
he said I don't know ah ah caught
red-handed
I don't know hat I don't know dude
not straight up lie no I don't know is
the best to say I don't know when you
know and you're trying to get out of not
being a [ __ ] you know in trouble or
whatever you think is the best I don't
know I don't know that's my favorite
kind of [ __ ] and that's final
so you can [ __ ] argue with me all day
long but that's my favorite kind of [ __ ]
and that's part because we know what we
like we know what daddy likes we know
what [ __ ] daddy likes daddy likes
when guys are [ __ ] sub itch and they
try to not be some [ __ ] that's the best
thing if a guy's wearing sunglasses at
night and bumps into a [ __ ] thing
that's my favorite thing and that's the
end of story dude okay that's why I like
[ __ ] horatio Caine so much dude the
shortest the shortest one ever and
that's why we have to find the killer so
quick dude what the [ __ ] is up with area
51 first of all are there 50 other areas
it's a bad stand up dude hey what's the
deal for area 51
what's the world like there's 50 other
areas just so many new audience yes all
right well you know I'm just saying
it'll more than that
yes okay okay well anyway what's going
on in the news that's what's going on in
the news listen man dude so so uh
I [ __ ] area 51 about how there's like
2.2 million people that however many
through many people I want to storm the
[ __ ] thing they can't they can't stop
us all hey dude yes they can they can't
stop us
do you know how many they can of you
they can stop do you know how many of
you they can stop all of you dude I
can't and that that is the definition of
first to go
anybody that goes I don't care if you're
a [ __ ] well-to-do person I don't care
what race you are I don't care how smart
you are I don't care if you're helping
the world I don't care what you do
barring you cure cancer if you show up
to raid area 51 I don't feel bad if you
get mowed down dude I mean dude are you
kidding me
the people that area 51 so I don't know
if you know this but there's like a
petition out there I was like hey we all
want to raid area 51 they can't stop us
all sign up and we're gonna all go at
some point which I hope is a joke I run
but I don't know anymore these days it's
his Facebook event right 1.5 right now
they can't stop all of us hosted by
shitposting because I'm in shambles okay
get a more professional name anyway we
will all meet up at the area 51 alien
Center tourist attraction and coordinate
our entry they have a plan before that
if we now root or run we can move faster
than their bullets okay well you can't
so I think this guy started as a joke
obviously but like there are people that
are for sure taking this seriously
because there are too many people now
people that area 51 are reading this and
they're loading their weapons and they
can't wait dude they can't wait bro they
can't wait hey do you mind giving me
that water Thanks there's they've been
waiting for this dude they're just
sitting there
like pretending I mean if there is
anything about aliens at area 51 like
there just been they've been waiting is
this real this is real Naruto running K
they're not Naruto running the regular
jogging with their hands behind their
[ __ ] so it's all good I mean they're
barely jogging so anyway
so anyway they're waiting and then and
when they start dude if I was at area 51
and they started Neruda running first of
all we're you gonna start from you got
to start from really far away because
their weapons go real far because their
guns they also have [ __ ] other things
other than guns if there really are
aliens there then they are checking out
the alien technology they're just gonna
[ __ ] boom like there's gonna be one
loud boom and people just gonna lose
their left just disintegrate it's gonna
be like the end of end Avengers or
whatever the [ __ ] endgame but ya know
rudl run all you want dude those
[ __ ] are in there they're ready
with their turrets bro and they'll get
all of you and they'll just [ __ ] load
them up I didn't won't even last that
long and that's it and somebody will be
done I'll be like weeks right no root Oh
God and then I will be in the front Joe
like you know I will be in the back like
I was playing I didn't really want to go
I just can't believe that also Naruto
running what we're looking at Naruto
running now on the on I mean dude it's
so [ __ ] to run with your hands behind
your back like that like I know this
Japanese [ __ ] they're trying to be like
this is the [ __ ] and in a way it kind of
is but it's so [ __ ] to run like that
dude Wow to run just like this mm-hmm
it's like you're trying to get away from
your mommy bro that's not no rutile
running you're try to get away from your
mommy dude wow you know what I really
want to see a [ __ ] 50 year old Naruto
run with a beli imagine Neruda running
and falling down but had taken one of
those long fall downs my favorite
falling downs are when people here's the
deal dude if you're gonna fall down just
[ __ ] fall right that's the way to do
it but if you're gonna fall down and you
keep trying and the momentum keeps
you over here like almost got I got got
and it takes more than a second or two
bro you win the cebiche award I want one
one time I saw a girl in high school we
were going to lunch first of all don't
ever run in your car unless like some
[ __ ] catastrophes happening I know a
guy Ian Edwards that [ __ ] hilarious
stand-up comedian who was comedies
comedy it's Comedy Central special just
came out I like that guy walked slower
than [ __ ] I can't imagine him ever I
know he'll never have kids because when
you have a kid you have to run you know
like if a kid falls down you got to run
over and make sure they're okay he'll
never have kids because he never I can't
even imagine
Ian running you have a friend imagine
that friend that you'd be like all he
would never run dude Ian Edwards would
never run for what I would be like go
Ian would you have a run and he'll be
like for wha um anyway uh yeah oh so
this chick was running to go to like a
lunch she's trying to like beat the
[ __ ] rush and she fell so hard and it
was so [ __ ] up cuz she had a lunchbox
and she was like two old devil lunchbox
cuz she was like [ __ ] in 9th or 10th
grade and she fell and had a lunchbox
and the lunchbox like opened and the
sandwich slid out you know and it was
like what the [ __ ] and she just goes ah
it was like the Peter Griffin thing
where he just keeps going and going oh
and I felt bad but you know what I did I
[ __ ] capable walking dude you fall
down you get up it's not how hard you
fall it's how quickly you get up and I
say that every morning dude and I also
say it sometimes on my podcast I guess
that girl was [ __ ] hot actually when
I was when I was a kid you know she was
she was she was that secret girl that
became hot all of a sudden one day you
know when you're in high school and like
the popular girls are hot and you're
like whoa hold on a second what's up
with Rebecca
because all of a sudden I don't know
it's like it's I don't know what that is
what is that it's just all of a sudden I
guess maybe puberty or maybe it's your
puberty or it's like this no hormones
and you're like you remember you were in
[ __ ] social studies class or math
class or some [ __ ] or you were in
[ __ ] Spanish class with mr. take ma
dude we had a Japanese Spanish teacher
and yet all sorts of accents and and and
I would you would just be looking over
at like [ __ ] Rebecca and you should
be like what the [ __ ] why all of a
sudden is she hot what happened it was
like the [ __ ] second she became hot
you know and you realize it and here's
how dumb guys are you think you're like
oh I'm the only guy who realizes that
now so I could probably get her and
she's like hey [ __ ] [ __ ] I've been
dealing with creepy fifty-year-olds
online for [ __ ] seven years but at
this point you're you you don't get me
dude and then she runs just runs to
lunch with lunchbox and she [ __ ]
falls down and that's just life that has
nothing to do with you know a clap back
or anything like that there's just you
just fell because sometimes people fall
you know and that's sad kinda but but
it's not really that sad though because
she's probably got a family now and even
though she [ __ ] fell down now she's
got kids at her [ __ ] Fallin that she
making lunch for and they're falling
down with their [ __ ] lunchbox and
[ __ ] but you know that's that girl's
name was I don't remember her name at
this point what she looks like now
everybody gets so [ __ ] ugly you know
unless you live in LA then you [ __ ]
rep all all all day long you rip all day
long for your whole life unless you get
[ __ ] fat but don't get fat and that's
it I've been looking at this old people
face app that people are doing everybody
did it even I did it I don't [ __ ]
like to do all this [ __ ] that everyone
does because you know good as [ __ ] but I
can't believe how crazy interesting and
good it look it's so good at it you know
and so I looked at the so I sent me some
of me and I did I didn't do it but
hosted one and they're so funny how good
everyone looks on it like actually like
handsome or pretty because it's like
dude it's not accounting that all of you
are gonna gain 40 pounds
I look like [ __ ] Logan on heroin on
mine or Samuel or not Samuel you see I'm
Elliott is that the guy the dude on the
dude the [ __ ] yeah I look like I
would've shaved his mustache a little
bit yeah so that old face app is pretty
wild though but it'll go away in two
[ __ ] days you know it's like it's
like one two days it was BAM everybody
everybody was doing it and then I'm gone
it sucks Bryan Callen can't do it right
because he's already that age I did it
too Bryan Callen and it was a [ __ ]
grave I did it too Bryan Callen and it
was a fire showed me a coffin and I was
like oh Jesus okay well oh good me
undies mm-hmm
I love me undies man I've never put on
underwear that's more comfortable and I
wear it every single day of my life
every single day of my life and you
should too it's weird it's got this
really great fabric that's like a lot
softer than cotton micromo tall it's
called me and these are here to change
your underwear not literally I mean but
it's here to change the way you think
about it and they believe undies
shouldn't take themselves too seriously
which I agree as well they believe on DS
should be soft fit every booty like it
was made for every booty and all for fun
patterns that give you the freedom to
express yourself there's new women's
products buy me undies they believe that
every woman should have the freedom to
wear whatever they whatever cut they
want and whatever color they want and
whatever size they want so ladies
rejoice the feel free collection is here
me undies size tested me undies size
tested these five new silhouettes on
everybody type with an ultra soft
feather-light waistband that provides
zero restriction these undies will be
the best thing that has ever been on
your body offered in sizes extra small
to 4 XL yeah I got ammo men I don't know
I mean I don't have the women's
underwear cuz I don't wear them but I
have all my underwear and I literally
love it I won't wear other underwear
how's that you got to try it
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to my undies comm /
Congrats that's me on DS comm / Congrats
today's show is brought to you by honey
the easiest way to save money when
you're shopping online look before I
found out about honey
seeing the promo code box at checkout
stressed me out like should I be typing
something in here is a code I don't know
like I don't know what it is how do I
find it and just knowing that there
could be a discount out there made me
worry about you know you am i overpaying
or they this is company taking money
from me every time I shop when they
don't need to be online and now I have
honey and it's a free tool that connects
to your computer's browser as you're
shopping so you don't have to do it
every time it scans the internet for
coupon codes and other discounts then it
automatically applies the best one to
your cart at checkout you save a lot of
money this way alright I'm telling you
honey we'll try we'll find you every
coupon code sale or discount on over
20,000 sites like Amazon j.crew eBay
Macy's Sephora Nordstrom and more one
fire one fire the producer here shops
online all day long and says it's always
saving him money and it does it
automatically he says it's like every
website that he shops on there's no
reason not to add honey to your browser
today it's free and to use it's free to
use and installs in just two clicks so
get honey for free at join honeycomb /
Congrats that's two words
join honey calm / Congrats honey the
easiest way to save money while shopping
online Stan's now I'm happy these guys
are sponsors because I've loved these
guys for years but because they've
changed the game when it comes to socks
I got him on right now as a matter of
fact I have the ones on that say Stan's
all over them that's how much I like
them look at that it says Stan's all
over these socks
they've all got these cool patterns and
they're very cool but they brought
creativity design and quality to what
was once a boring accessory there are
plenty of pretenders out there but
Stan's started it all and they're the
best at it if you're one of the millions
of people who
fallen in love with stance you already
know why the sock world and your feet
haven't been the same since incredible
design and comfort and unmet durability
from everyday casual styles they have
like cool patterns that are just like
kind of more muted and and and and and
easy and then also they have like the
crew socks that are like and then
performance athletic socks with cool
vibrant designs I mean it's just they're
the best stance gives back to the
community of socks for Heroes which
sends socks to deployment to deployed
military around the world it's very cool
collaborations that raise money for
clean water initiatives in Africa
California wildfire victims and breast
cancer awareness campaigns it's just a
really good sound great company and
they've they're the best well that sucks
so stance has great great offer for my
listeners you go to Stan's comm /
Congrats you'll get a free pair of socks
with a purchase st ance comm / congrats
to get your free pair of socks this is a
limited time offer so take advantage
today and go to Stan's comm / Congrats
if they're not Stan's they're just socks
it's really cool man where I'm out
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the official app of the log
cabin better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals you know I mean
sometimes I have like anxiety that that
gets in the way of me doing what I need
to do and all that stuff but introducing
better help it will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 24 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online it's good for people and it's you
know it's sometimes you need this and
you can't get a quick appointment but
you can hear there is a broad range of
expertise in better helps counselor
network which may not be locally
available in
areas it's available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
chat and text with your therapist even
between sessions visit better help calm
/ Congrats and join the over 500,000
people talking taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
Congrats drinking on your ass
drinking water on your ass because you
know because actually that's the end of
the sentence but yeah so we got a cameo
here
I got a cameo somebody got this for me
as a joke it's from Lance Bass let me
play it how's it going Chris Lance Bass
here I'd like to remind you to give her
congratulations podcast sponsors a bit
more love and personal endorsements we'd
hate to see those new sponsors say
bye-bye
keep the Brinks trucks bill and get that
log ABBA money that's Lance Bass you
know it's cool I like Lance Bass so
thanks for that did you know that
there's new emojis Apple's new iOS will
allow users to vary the skin tone of
emojis with two or more people oh so
they're gettin well mixed race couples
up in this [ __ ] one fire sent me this
link like he's trying to end my career
talking about this just gettin [ __ ]
trouble so here are the different
versions you can do white white girl
with Somalian guy I'm just looking at
what that looks like
you can also just
white girl with pedophile guy white guy
with moustache
tan surfer dude with white chick white
chick with maybe really tan maybe he's
Mexican guy then just white chick with
black guy and then a blonde chick with
black guy I mean these are all the
bitter grades is great dude finally this
is great I mean that sucks that we had
to use black with black and white with
white now Apple dude you can literally
get an Indian girl holding hands with a
[ __ ] white chick dude I guess we
figured it out well you know woke in the
best way dude emojis accept each other
now I mean dude I'm gonna buy Apple for
life what so many you can get a little
black girl names a little black girl you
get a Mexican guy holding hands as a
black girl you can get a white dude
holding hands with a Somalian dude
black dude gig just a regular black dude
with a regular black chick you just get
that going on too so that's cool also
there's other new emojis there's a guy
pointing to his face so that's cool
because I know that was in [ __ ] high
demand I hated when I would be like when
I had to text hey guys I'm pointing to
my face now I could just send that emoji
over a banjo so that's cool because
anyone who plays a banjo for sure has an
iPhone even though they're in [ __ ]
19:12
a yawn emoji which is actually a good
one there's a golden retriever okay
there's a crossing guard vest and that's
it and that's really important
what the [ __ ] would you need a crossing
guard vest emoji for there's an a
gorilla like a hardcore gorilla just
sitting down um a robot of robot arm
kind of flexing conning away then
there's an like I guess that would be a
what is that like Hindi garb I don't
know what that is
whatever it is I'm racist probably then
there's a sloth cool then there's a
black chick holding hands lil black
chick that's probably just to show the
other emojis and then there's butter a
lot is that what is that falafel balls
or what the [ __ ] what
yeah falafel balls for you Greek
[ __ ] Oh a blind chick that's
cool because blind people who don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're texting so
okay a skunk and Ice Cube that's cool
for me when I'm talking about my jewelry
on text there's a parachuting guy a
one-piece bathing suit garlic clove a
flamenco
flamingo flamingo flamingo then there's
a hearing aid that's good for my dad and
then there's other ones robot leg
interracial couple and then a [ __ ]
eggo waffle guys I also am recording
this episode I'm trying to not talk
about things that are happening to
currently because I don't know when this
episode is gonna air because I'm kind of
I'm like you know I'm maybe going to
maybe we'll come out this week maybe
I'll Bank it I don't know because I'm
gonna be an Albuquerque I don't know how
busy I'm gonna be
but I gotta admit something to you guys
and I am I meant to start off this
episode with an apology because I'm
recording it on world hot dog day and I
apologize because I know I should be
taking the day off you know because it's
world hot dog day
and III but I thought you know what even
though it's a national even though it's
an international holiday and it's very
important even though it's very
important important even though it's
extremely important I thought I gotta
give you guys what you want even though
I should take the entire day off and
strictly eat hot dogs so you're welcome
or something or as my brother's friend
would say in middle school are saying so
I'm really sorry but I had to work on
National Hot Dog Day also Channing Tatum
can you get the camera closer to your
face on Instagram videos is it in your
brain and I'm gonna comment right now on
this thing we're kissing because that's
what's happening if I'm not close to
somebody I'm kissing kissing I don't
know whatever I mean you know I still
don't know why he lists his [ __ ]
podcast you know it is what it is right
and ain't none true or none true or not
true
nuttin true or not true you know it's
like being a guy I'm only 39 okay
I mean I'm [ __ ] I challenge you to
find someone younger than me because I
[ __ ] been trying to actively find
someone younger than me for a month and
I can't find one and but this is what
it's like being a guy cleared out the
garage cleared out the garage cleared
out my garage and can't stop thinking
about it cleared out the garage
and I can't stop thinking about it dude
I woke up today got in one of my cars
and [ __ ] left and couldn't stop
thinking about how my other car was in
my garage cuz it's been cleared out dude
and I drove to get coffee and I was I
never stopped thinking about how my
garage was clear so you know what dude
[ __ ] you you try to put me in a bad mood
today no matter what happens I won't be
dude because my garage is clear and I'll
tell you what dude that [ __ ] rocks as
a guy having a clear garage yo and I'm
not even I'm not even 40 dude I'm the
youngest guy you'll ever meet
and yea of course my shoulders they go
on you know whatever fine it's fine yeah
I'm shooting the movie army of the Dead
and they did asked about renting out
space you know on my back to shoot some
of the [ __ ] movie and I said you know
I don't know I'm forgetting you know
what they say everybody has a price I
was I I already got [ __ ] some of the
Lord of the Rings [ __ ] that they did
they shot there and I didn't like the
mess they left you know but yeah so my
garage is clear and and if you're trying
to put me in a bad mood world Oh Oh bro
hey [ __ ] you my garage is clear okay and
one of my cars is in there so drink to
that
hello anytime I hear this clinking ice
clinking I think hello mister bombed
it's so British to have ice in a glass
and clink it and you know what do it and
I'm gonna don't give off yo what
what else should we talk about man
should we take some questions or should
we that's what it's like being a guy
though is getting your [ __ ] dialed in
chicks too though so really that's what
it's like being a guy er chick we
figured that out man I'm a [ __ ] idiot
want to talk a Twitter take Twitter
questions or something like that did you
see a video about the guy I almost threw
up in his mouth and a [ __ ] I did it
on h3 we talked about on h3 tag almost
threw up in his mouth dude when you
almost throw up in your mouth this guy
[ __ ] threw I don't know it's like a
Swedish Swedish um throw-up in mouth see
if I can find it if we talk about an h3
a video was a Swedish even I don't even
know where it is sir it is Finnish polit
Finnish Finnish politician vomits vomits
in his own mouth I talk we talked about
on h3 but we'll do it here - yes so
nervous dude have you seen this season
eight seconds seven sevens axes and
there it is any smoothly
that's gangsters now I want that guy to
be my father
do you understand if you're first of all
he had four minutes to talk and he was
nervous the whole time and in the
[ __ ] final five seconds his body was
like you know what [ __ ] it and it came
up and he goes like uh like a like
someone who can Naruto run like like a
JEP japanimation like and then he just
goes no you're not oh hey throw up
I'm in charge of my body
my mouth doesn't open if I don't say it
does and then swallows it back up and
and and room in the remaining second
ticks by that guy hey guy
congratulations I'm related to you
because I won't I am I or I say you're
related to me thank you for that because
that you're my you're partly in my top
five heroes that's gangster I would open
my mouth and thrown the [ __ ] up and I
and I would have let it happen and I
would have been like that's what you get
man that's what happens you know but
this guy finished politician vomits in
his own mouth during interview swallows
it and continues talking do you
understand somebody writes true warrior
under it Wow that's amazing
vomit look at these top five puking
fails let's look at these I mean do you
don't need to grab it for it you know
it's just to show the videos top five
puking has got a graphic
oh wow dude I'm gonna send this to you
oh wow dude I mean that one's hilarious
this guy is in a parking lot throws up
and someone walking by an older lady
walking by just falls down because of it
like straight up doesn't even [ __ ] in I
just sent emailed it to you you have it
you have it I mean she just falls the
[ __ ] down dude with her bags when you
fall down with bags that's it that's how
the girl looked in my high school that
fell down she goes to run away and she's
holding her [ __ ] granddaughters hand
okay now we got a little girl
Wow I love that that was like at a
[ __ ] grocery store parking lot now we
got a little girl in like a wizard hat
and she's doing a play or something oh
she's cute oh and she just threw the
[ __ ] up like it was part of the play
how does throw-up become oh she's
killing it Wow that's not how did that
come did they siphon that through her
butthole how did she get that much in
her wow that's amazing these guys
already deserve it I can tell this is
the number three and these guys already
deserve it and I can tell cuz these guys
all straight-up I swear to God Arlie are
Theo von fans you can tell one guy's
wearing a Louisville shirt another guys
wearing a wife-beater and they're in a
kitchen that you would be molested in a
hundred percent and another guy I don't
even know how to describe the other guy
I mean he just looked he looks like he
would be on every [ __ ] any small any
town where they were like and we're
going live to the street to see what the
deal is they'd be interviewing that guy
and there's a big big big big McDonald's
Cup on the [ __ ] thing don't ever get
the big big big me to the McDonald's Cup
that's too big and then it daddy that it
has to [ __ ] get smaller so it'll fit
in cupholders if you get that drink
you're first to go
get the [ __ ] out of life get a [ __ ]
drink that just fits in your cup holder
don't get one that has different sizes
in it what is it transformer I can't
even tell her allah allah he threw up on
CL bond time
you ever seen a [ __ ] Theo von fan
throw up on the Theo von fan look at
that one right there here's a baby and
the lady is holding it up a lots gonna
throw up right on her face and that's
obvious good she deserves it
Oh cute mummy our cue baby oh that's so
cute dude I want to have a son and have
him throw up on me now this guy's
picking up a goddamn I mean why are
wheels so [ __ ] big you know in this
guy's got not only it's one thing to
take the big truck wheel and toss it
over as a workout guy you know what I
mean and throw it over or take the
mallet and [ __ ] smash it but this
guy's got a [ __ ] whole apparatus
attached to the big ass wheel that you
weight train with it says weight
training cardio and fitness zone full
strongman facilities and this guy's got
the apparatus in his hand and he's going
to pick it up and my guess is he's going
to upchuck all over the whole [ __ ]
weight training facility okay let's see
and he pulled it down and it goes up
again and it goes up again and down
again
okay let a little bit of throw-up out
and then just kind of [ __ ] still okay
and grew up again and he's still going
okay hey bud okay Oh bull came out his
nose oh he's okay
[Applause]
okay well guys I'm a monster huh
my god this guy April once you start
throwing up stop that's my whole motto
do whatever I'm doing I mean the guy
kept going hey guy
stop hey oh all the doctors in the world
stopped
that's them guy throws up nine times
while lifting up a [ __ ]
tractor-trailer all doctors in the world
stop Wow God
that's amazing I think they put a
[ __ ] tarp down it was that what that
is yeah they put a tarp down in front of
them like maybe like this guy was the
throb guy
hey we got time he come and he's a
[ __ ] throw-up guy so put the tarp
down he's gonna lift seven times this
goddamn thing that nobody should lift
seven times and he's absolutely gonna
throw up some put the top down cuz he
always throws up we got Tommy going so
it's all good let's look at some
questions we haven't looked ups
questions on a long time do we have
actually do we have a questions do we
even have a yeah mr. questions okay the
[ __ ] I'm sorry the best one was when
the guy threw up in the parking lot and
the and the girl fell and that was
number five that should have been number
one because it's so funny that there's
two family this is so funny she throws
off oh wow
kind of an older woman fall it's sad as
[ __ ] huh um alright so what do I do
we got Twitter okay cool
remember this whole [ __ ] member of the
[ __ ] gaming the system guy dude why
okay first of all don't misspell does
this guy real wide dose this lady why
does this lady Luis bandit Lois spanned
at 666 well any 666 changing but why
does this lady have the same first name
as your full name Chris D'Elia is a
crystal Leah crystal 'ÿä j ry s t al Li
a how about how our last name is Kalyan
Kelly MC I mean Chris Thalia Kelly
auntie I mean this sexiest goddamn name
of all time cristela Akane auntie did
she a Bond girl she's a prize as a
project manager Wow
two likes nice bro cool congratulations
Potter alright great next one I
no man you know what you're asking me I
don't [ __ ] know I've become I get
high
and tweet okay you know and I love how
the handle that's the thing dude that's
so far the handle is I get high and twee
one because they wanted it to be end
tweet and then so to let you know their
hand their [ __ ] header or whatever you
would call it their name on it I get
high in tweet like just [ __ ] have it's
a Lisa or whatever your name is dude we
we got it all so change it both I get
high in tweet one royal [ __ ] are you
the lady that fell when the guy threw up
I've become very aware of how much I
complain since listening -
congratulations pot an unexpected life
life lesson Thank You Senor Dahlia Senor
I don't I don't even get that what are
you saying cuz I cuz I complain or cuz I
make fun of people who complain or what
what are you high right now you're high
right now dude
stop eating so many [ __ ] weed
brownies um yeah also here's another
thing about people uh you know I joke
'only call myself daddy and [ __ ] and
like you know I call you guys babies
don't come up to me and say and call me
Dad people think it's like I do not I'm
not dad dude daddy alright people dude
some guy came up to me and said can I
get a pic and he started taking a video
and I was like and I was like ah [ __ ]
what are you doing bro and he was like
hey I'm with my dude he [ __ ] was so
nervous for us all he's shaking and he
said hey what's up Instagram I'm with my
grandpappy ah dude you're a [ __ ]
mistake I'm with my grand Pappy ah that
was ultimate cringe I literally on his V
I'm on his video going like this ah
what
you get the real deal when you come out
dude okay here's a good one
rob em at rob matera 27 all right cool
fine no change it involved saw this
woman while driving yesterday and rolled
my window down to give her a drive-by
hey your thoughts on this loon and what
she's protesting okay so she's just next
to a stop sign and this big banner says
danger and then under it robotic
equipment is being implanted into you
and your kids during surgery with your
onion with your informed consent that
with what Oh without your informed
consent sorry she's not holding the
banner right if you're gonna go through
the whole [ __ ] trouble hold the
banner right you got a huge banner get a
friend oh but you don't have any because
you're alone
this means slavery Oh it gets real more
of it at the end during surgery without
your informed consent this means slavery
and torture by remote control until you
die dude this guy took this picture what
a shot also get a better location
she just didn't you know where she is
some neighborhood near a stop sign dude
where is it see if you can see where do
you put that location robot equipment is
not being implanted in your who's this
[ __ ] who's holding that who's behind
the sign Sam Tripoli dude Sayreville New
Jersey I've played there before I think
wow man New Jersey nothing's for who's
the crazier state Florida or New Jersey
I'd have to say Florida because of how
big it is but man nothing's more New
Jersey than Florida nothing's more New
Jersey than a New Jersey guy moving down
to Florida and being in Florida
that's the most New Jersey you can be
it's like when I found out that a a
while ago I don't know if he still does
but Johnny Depp lives in Paris I was
like dude that's the most Hollywood you
can be nothing's more New Jersey than
living in Florida and just having a
belly feel like yeah you know I like it
because you know it doesn't get cold I
can't deal with the [ __ ] cold you
know I can't deal with the seasons I
honestly I've deal I've dealt with the
seasons for 54 years I can't [ __ ]
deal with it anymore
I got to come down here I got to catch
some rays that's it that's it I come out
here I eat my [ __ ] bologna sandwiches
and I smoked a cigar and I'm gonna do
that and I'll tell you what if it shaves
life off the back of my mm you know at
the end of my life it doesn't matter
because those are the [ __ ] bad years
anyway I'm talking about them living as
best as I can from now until those years
start and that's it and that's [ __ ]
it
what is mukbang YouTube culture Briana
Marie prosper at canora's Pollock's okay
change it I have ill Chris they have you
talked to mukbang YouTube culture yet
converges right observe and report it
that's my one fire saying people eat a
lot of food mukbang while they talk
while they okay I'm looking it up
mukbang oh it's that Korean [ __ ] where
they eat like [ __ ] squids and and
break [ __ ] yeah that's gross I can't
I can't watch that [ __ ] you know what
eating is honestly a [ __ ] private
thing even restaurants it's like what
the [ __ ] are we doing we're all getting
together to [ __ ] shove [ __ ] in our
faces it seems like it should be like
sex you don't [ __ ] you know in public
and [ __ ] you know eating is like an it
should be like a it's so intimate we're
inserting [ __ ] you know it's as gross
most people unless you're hot as [ __ ]
unless you're a Niner above you should
just be eating by yourself in your house
dude if you're at 10 restaurants should
only be for tens for real like even I I
think I like to consider myself I you
know I'd like to take care of my body
like I have you trihard maybe you know
with your body and workout and you tried
you know mostly on only people who
should be eating in restaurants or hot
chicks that don't use that much makeup
because that's gross to eat with a bunch
of makeup on or if you're like a
top-notch [ __ ] good-looking dude like
Brad Pitt Tom Cruise you know what I
mean I'm talking about Paul Walker if he
was alive rest in peace he could be at a
restaurant maybe Hugh Jackman I don't
really know I haven't seen him up close
but like Ryan Reynolds I guess could eat
with his wife out in public but like bro
you're just gonna look like a [ __ ]
gross guy and and then put stuff in your
face in public with other like nah eat
in private so mukbang go [ __ ] yourself
okay eating for all the world to see
gross at least I can click on the link
about if I if I choose but like just
mostly eating let private okay
private um
anyway well you know that's an hour so
you know I had a good that was fun that
was a fun episode and I hope you enjoyed
it and if you didn't enjoy it it doesn't
matter because that was for me
[Applause]
so [ __ ] how it [ __ ] fades out uh
it's weird how it can be some [ __ ] even
though it fades out that way like it's
it is it's like said quickly the
quickness of fading out I never think
song should fade out that's so 80s and
90s song should just stop so it should
be 2 minutes and 20 seconds and that
said I've always said that and my dad
once I said it to my dad and he was like
you're [ __ ] out of your mind and I
was like what songs more for too long
you know uh anyway it's cool how I feel
[ __ ] tingly and numb in my thumb
great great it's all good I feel tingly
and numb in my thumb but I'm Jung Lee
[ __ ] so it's all good so cool maybe I
set the desk all good thanks for
listening you guys are great had a good
time and my garage is [ __ ] cleared
out and one of my cars is in there [ __ ]
yeah I'm happy about that and and that's
it and I'm gonna be in [ __ ]
Albuquerque a lot dude and it is dry as
[ __ ] and I'm trying to [ __ ] go number
two get out of here get out of here dude
number two in Albuquerque get out of
here [ __ ] in thanks for listening you
guys are the best oh and remember to
check out my brothers podcast Maithili
is confused and download my app on on
you can get it and listen to and see
there sometimes I do podcasts on a
Wednesday you guys don't even know about
it but the my app does cuz I do podcast
on a Wednesday and they download and
they subscribe and then they get to
catch it in the first 10 minutes 15
minutes alive before it even goes out
download download the cash up for free
on the App Store or Google Play market
support the show by buying merch at
store dot Chris D'Elia calm stored
crystal calm or you just go to crystal
calm and follow the [ __ ] links but
you can get all these shirts futures too
bright shirt and where I'm at Bryan
Callen shows you got to start wearing
more of them at Bryan Callen shows I was
at the king in this sting show the other
day and I popped up to do us I saw some
freak what's a free concert and some
dent shirts and they didn't know I was
gonna be on the lineup I guess
spotted I just [ __ ] popped on and bro
you're wearing those a sting in the fit
and the thing you're wearing those that
[ __ ] thing in the stim do it you're
wearing on my [ __ ] stem sting in the
bring and you guys ring and ring the
ring of the Bing dude and you guys are
[ __ ] wearing my merch
I've bling in the fing dude that's the
[ __ ]
what is that even [ __ ] podcasting in
the ring what do they talk about it's
just too [ __ ] dude
Theo's hair I saw a picture the other
day of Theo a profile shot of Theo and
it was unreal bro I was like I literally
out loud go like this
wow that's it's amazing it's amazing
that you think like that who's that guy
okay
subscribe to the YouTube channel got
shows coming up and it's great come out
catch the follow-the-leader torque it's
almost over the poly the leader tort is
almost over end of the year and that's
it and I got to start working on new
material of my babies so catch it before
it [ __ ] before it goes away you guys
Rock thanks for listening and remember
[Music]